foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yes it's Tuesday
everybody good to you all so an army of
Seven Nations can't stop his Trump
frustrations former rock star Jack White
just got pissy over people being polite
to the former Prez and since his music
has been selling about as well as a
hunter Biden painting
white decided to make headlines the
old-fashioned way by reminding people
that you are evil if you ever Shake
Trump's hand the disgruntled grunter
wrote on Instagram anybody who
normalizes or treats this disgusting
fascist racist con man disgusting pieces
Trump with any level of respect is also
disgusting in my book and that's you Joe
Rogan you Mel Gibson you Mark Wahlberg
you Guy Fieri
Guy Fieri he went there
to punctuate his Keen analysis white
included pictures of these evil
celebrities at Saturday's UFC event
mingling and shaking hands with evil
Trump Gibson Wahlberg FJR Fieri Rogan it
sounds like he's listing people way more
successful than him
by the way the Gibson photos actually
from 2021 as if that matters because
then white added this is a statement
from me not a discussion or debate
well I'm glad he cleared that up I was
just about to invite him to my book club
well too bad Jack because you are a big
phony you sung at Loretta Lynn's funeral
and she endorsed Trump so knock it off
and debate is kind of what we do here in
the good old us of a yeah pale PUD
pulling pissant
it was alliterative but what a typical
left wing or all he cares about is Trump
while people beat each other up in cages
for money
so what were Rogan and Wahlberg supposed
to do anyway tackle Trump to the ground
and try to peel back his orange devil
mask
maybe that's what Jack White would do he
doesn't seem like a people person this
was his reaction when he realized Take
Me Out to the Ball Game
is more popular than anything he's ever
written by the looks on his face he
appears to have mistaken his seat for a
porto potty
yeah
but none of this bothers me and it
doesn't bother you who cares what white
thinks anyway this is a monologue merely
to remind you that only stupid people
still use the phrase normalize by
shaking Trump's hands you normalize
Trump
nearly 80 million people voted for the
guy some of them were once your fans
he's our 45th president you can't get
much more normalized than that these
days
but with these whiny Stars it's always
about normalizing and weaponizing but
rarely ever civilizing I mean going
after Guy Fieri he's like the nicest guy
in the world
sure he's got hair like a lesbian
firefighter
[Laughter]
true
but he raised over 25 million bucks to
help restaurant workers during the
pandemic and Mark Wahlberg everybody
knows he's an active supporter of
veterans Charities but more important he
led the Funky Bunch
that brought tame rap music in ABS to
millions of pre-teens who needed it
badly but Wahlberg lost cool points for
being too nice to Trump
but again that's Jack White's problem
again you see how intensely some
children have been broken by Trump so
much so that being civil in public
becomes an evil endorsement I once held
a door open for Brian Kilmeade it
doesn't mean I don't hate him
but it shows you that white isn't
interested in Solutions rather he's part
of the problem a recent study claims
nasty politics haven't been higher since
the Civil War which is kind of funny
since they said that first under Trump
and blamed him for it but now it's worse
under a Democrat so what's that tell you
well that it never was about trump it
was the overwrought response to him like
this dweeb now you could call it white
supremacy Jack white supremacy
I know clever huh
Elites who felt so Superior to those
deplorables who won in 2016 uh that they
had to weaponize their celebrity to
marginalize these trumpers they
normalize degradation to Millions which
is what Hitler did see I can be a
liberal too
but even if you don't respect the man in
office you're allowed to respect the
Office of the President it's all part of
growing up for example I still respect
the office of President even though Joe
Biden keeps forgetting he's in it
hey remember the time Joe tried to shake
hands with me
[Applause]
[Music]
well at least I was there in spirit so
Jack quit acting like a mean girl and
get back to the music I just heard some
of your most recent stuff oh
I'm gonna fight them all
a Seven Nation Army couldn't hold me
back they're gonna rip it off
taking their time right behind my back
Seven Nation Army
nice
better than his older stuff
period let's welcome tonight's get she
has eight points on her license for
talking too fast most of the fox true
crap podcast Emily cabango
don't you dare applaud him he's
frightened by unfamiliar sounds
award-winning comedian Kurt Metzger
the doctor has to put the blood pressure
cuff around her waist Fox News
contributor tattoo
and at the gym his spotters also need
spotters my massive sidekick in the
nwa's World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Emily uh would this ever mean anything
to you if it was somebody else like this
is I just find this story so silly
that's why I did it but isn't it funny I
mean like if would this actually bother
you if it was somebody you really really
cared about you mean that it was Jack
White saying that or about Trump yeah no
and I think you you hit the nail on the
head so many times in your monologue oh
thank you that it's um that it's Jack
White's problem yeah and it's emblematic
of everyone with derangement syndrome
it's emblematic of everyone with the
approach to Trump that he is the end-all
be-all and it means nothing whether
you've raised 25 million for the
restaurant industry whether you've saved
animals and children where you've
elevated the the dialogue and the
intellectual caliber of this country
whether you were part of Marky Mark and
the Funky Bunch which is the number one
thing that you could ever do to make
life amazing it doesn't matter about all
those contributions if you've got a
Funky Bunch weren't they if you voted
for Trump we've covered it on this show
they don't want
they don't want to date you they don't
want to have you room with them in
college it's the absolute final point to
end and sever any type of relationship
whatsoever and never mind the fact that
yes he was our president and served a
full term but that he lowered
unemployment rates for underserved
communities and minorities and elevated
education rates for the same that
there's a reason why those in minority
populations were flocking to his
policies and to him still to this day
including double-digit points in States
like the list goes on of how that person
and his policies affected Americans for
the better but people like Jack White
will never see beyond that and they'll
never see beyond the contributions
positively of those people that dared to
shake his hand to then sever them
publicly you know Kurt it's a funny it's
a funny contrast because it happens at
an MMA fight and like Jack White's upset
that they shook hands it's like it's an
Emma it's it's just so bizarre I mean
he's got blue hair dude but I I like
I thought like The Apprentice normalized
Trump maybe I believe the moment yes
when he was normalized with Jeff Zucker
that's when they gained a function to
Trump yeah and he leaked out and they
got a whole panic and had to lock
everything down yes
uh you know and I never dreamed that
liberal darling Guy Fieri
but they all loved Guy Fieri before this
yeah
uh has now become the Dylan Mulvaney of
people who watched densaki yeah it is
true though because like all of the
people that claim how disgusting Trump
is were all over him for 25 30 years did
you read the Guy Fieri restaurant
reviews yes restaurant came out yeah
they were better than what they were not
as good as what Jack White said yeah
exactly
cat did this break your heart as a fan
of the White Stripes
no I'm still a fan and I still think
he's hot before
Edward Scissorhands speaking of hot uh
we should watch this what
how will the show be different in our
new time slot
well for one thing we're going to give
the viewers what they've been asking for
which is 10 less Greg
Gutfeld now airing one hour earlier
beginning July 17th
[Music]
why are you applauding yeah
does that mean we get out early I wish
or that mean does that mean you're going
to give us 10 more cat
I don't have more to give
yeah that's above my pay bracket yeah
just shave a little Greg off yes exactly
I'm just gonna speak less so it doesn't
feel like it's 10 but I'll still be here
yeah well okay so Jack White yes I think
he could use more ideological diversity
in the circle that he hangs out in
because he I guess saying something like
this thinks that a lot of people are
gonna be like yeah
you don't want to demonize huge segments
of the population you're really also
kind of cheating yourself because there
could be people who vote a certain way
that you might have something in common
with I think that the left is worse at
this I think the right can do it too if
you're somebody who's like in a comment
section like Democrats I call them demon
rats like you also need to go outside
and meet a person who are you imitating
there the internet
uh he's got blue hair I mean what do you
want yeah I just I think that really
we're not doing ourselves any favors
because this is how the government gains
more power by pushing us against each
other pitting us against each other
we're all distracted and then they just
gain more and more control over us
listen I I get it record sales are down
if your TV ratings are down if you you
know your your girl's mad at you blame
Trump yeah because everyone goes what
Trump so we're talking about
this guy I don't even know who the hell
he is because he did what he punched up
went after everybody
and he said Trump and Trump is the magic
word if you say Trump people will pay
attention so but you forget in a
capitalistic Society you want everyone
to buy your stuff so you're pissed off
half the country
and then you went and maybe all the
countries not hip on politics but they
love Wahlberg they love they love Mel
everyone loves the little cook guy
and you just piss them off so there's
let's say 25 yeah so now you have a
perfectly good excuse when you go back
to your manager goes it's not my fault
that three quarters of the country and
the planet hates me because he has no
record sales so this is how you get
relevant we see it all the time
reporters are doing it for book deals
Acosta was doing his thing and then
where is he now yeah they I think he's
on CNN plus I think yeah he's doing over
here can I tell you why I was at Trump
um because how come he used to do all
the edgy material yes
yes
Trump's bills are paid for yeah you know
what I'm saying it's like my truck's
paid for cancel me I don't care I'll go
fishing like when you get to a point
where you don't care about what the
so-called masses said you just move on
you're someone's truck is paid for too
you know what I'm talking about because
I can get in my truck and drive away
yes it's like being cancer-free
cancer-free cancer-free I'm cancel free
cancel I've paid all my stuff oh yeah so
I don't got to fly a couple extra weeks
a month cool I'm out yeah all right hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else